loja rejects its Greg Alba here I found
out this morning from first person to
inform me about this was the wonderful
Marnie Kaka
I think that's how you say her name
don't want to make a joke about that
last name Marnie kako she told me about
the Beauty and the Beast trailer the
official one droppings he's a subscriber
and she has a really cool special
effects makeup page where she has some
really kind of disturbing makeup designs
but I really think it's worth checking
out put a link in the description box so
you could check out her effects she's a
wonderful lady really cute Brit chick I
believe she's British yes yes I remember
a conversation now let's watch this Emma
Watson the lovely Emma Watson lover is
me
creepy
you must leave here discuss is kevin
kline do you wish to take your father's
place come into the light is that that
bad looking
show me the girl look at her what if she
is the one dawn will break this man
whoa it's brought alive
the nurses noticed terrible as he
appears
I'm gonna love this
be our guest oh I'm there I Alex really
[ __ ] awesome man I'm really I'm
really stoked for that film I mean a lot
like the you know the a lot of these
other adaptations from Disney bringing
it to live-action it does it looks like
it's gonna play out exactly like the
original film so to review like this
story of this trailer would just be like
reviewing the original awesome animated
film which I saw probably like twice in
my life over ten years ago but what
we're getting here man
like a lot of the things I was kind of
concerned about when I heard they're
adapting and a lot of that has been put
to rest the effects of everyone looks
spectacular Dan Stevens as the beast he
sounds like almost exactly like the
Beast it's kind of crazy like from the
original cartoon
it looks like exactly like the cartoon
which I love because it's brought to
life in a very specific way where it's a
good mix of looking like the cartoon but
having a darker reality touch to it
which I really appreciate because I mean
you could go with a zany kind of look
what that doesn't really work out well
no one really likes that people would
just feel like I'd rather watch the
cartoon so this is a great way to bring
it to life the Beast he kind of looks
like a goat I feel like the Beast kind
of looks a little too handsome like he
just looks like a guy who's really hairy
if I'm gonna be honest that's my one
complaint about this trailer I was
expecting a much more intimidating like
when you see the beast in the cartoon
he's terrifying when you first see him
he's like massive and here he just looks
like a you know like one of those guys
would see him like Guinness Book World
Records of dudes who's super hairy
I wish the beast was just a little bit
more menacing looking I feel like you I
really he's still a pretty handsome dude
that's feel a little bit like female
brainwashing though it's okay for the
Hawkgirl the date the ugly guy because
he's filthy rich
that's why no one dates me
and while this trailer is providing a
lot of that epic sweeping kind of movie
magic vibe
one thing I would like more of in like
I'm sure they're gonna release another
trailer I would like to see a little bit
more of the humor actually Beauty and
the Beast is a funny movie there's a lot
of fun-filled stuff yeah there's a lot
of dark stuff in there too but you know
come on is the live-action Disney
adaptation I'm sure we're gonna get some
good laughs in here I'm really impressed
by the lighting of this film like the
lighting of this film is what makes all
the special effects seem like it's
actually working but a good visual
effects like this you need a very
specific kind of tonal lights in order
to make the effects look real and
believable because we're dealing with
heavy amounts of CGI here I mean I don't
remember the names but the clock guy and
the candle dude they look great and Emma
Watson I thought she was beautiful since
Harry Potter to every part of tews and I
started finding her cute chamber of
secrets Prisoner of Azkaban as well I
was thinking she's pretty hot and we're
on the same age
I'm sure movie star Emma Watson would be
just as interested in minor YouTube
personality Greg Alva I mean while I
could sit here and say like I like this
trailer - I like this movie to branch
out and bring us a lot of things we
haven't seen out of Beauty and the Beast
I think this is kind of cool still to
just see the cartoon that we love
brought to life and it's done in a way
where it's like it does look believable
one thing I'd like more out of the next
trailer or at least when I just watch
the actual movie is to see you know the
a great love story here because it was a
beautiful love story you know watching
this lovely lady fall in love with a
beast you know cuz I feel like a lot of
men it's a great metaphor for how you
know men are beastly I'm a beast mm
[ __ ] beast baby look I know this is a
kids movie and a lot of kids probably
watching this trailer reaction so kids
close your ears but you know Belle and
the Beast
well need i say more they [ __ ] really
rough my favorite character in the
cartoon was guest on Luke Evans kind of
iffy about sometimes I like him
sometimes I'm just whatever about him I
didn't really see him as being the guy
to be cast in this for guest on this
trailer is like it's showing us a lot of
the cool visual effects and showing us
looks like the cartoon what I really
want to see though is
I want there to be cool character still
I want the personalities really brought
to life
I want the romance to really be felt I
want you know guest on is the villain to
be very funny and same time you want him
to die because he did you see that fight
scene that he has with a beast which is
gonna be cool and I don't know I mean
something tells me this film is probably
gonna make me cry this films probably
gonna make me cry and I hope there's an
unrated director's cut where we get a
really rough sex scene with Emma Watson
and the Beast because who the [ __ ]
wouldn't watch that and I guess the big
question is I'm sure maybe they talked
about it in some behind-the-scenes
reports but is there gonna be musicals
in there because the most memorable
thing out of Beauty and the Beast is the
musical numbers and kind of like a
jungle book included a few I'm hoping
that they do that here I'm sure they
will I hope it sounds good I mean this
is from the guy who brought us the last
couple Twilight films you know Breaking
Dawn Part 2 is considered to be the best
one of the Twilight films which is
saying so much anyway yeah that's a
really cool trailer glad I was told that
was out thank you Marty anybody rejects
if you're new to the channel subscribe
today and get accepted follow me on you
know what I don't want to say it you
just if you care to follow me on social
media go ahead hit me up on Instagram
that's where I tend to be ladies if you
want to talk to a beast
it's my beast roar for you that's sexy
I'm so seductive